[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
en nuestro continente a continuación
algunos de los temas que vamos a tratar
en el programa de hoy
hablaremos de la actualidad
epidemiológica en eeuu el presidente de
ese país joe biden pidió al congreso más
fondos para su lucha contra la pandemia
al tiempo que la rda también autorizó
una dosis de refuerzo adicional para los
mayores de 50 años daremos un vistazo al
número de casos y al avance de la
vacunación en ese país norteamericano en
sólo unos minutos
también la organización mundial de la
salud lado ms planteó tres escenarios
sobre el futuro de la pandemia de kobe
19 la organización explicó las
estrategias clave para ser llevadas a
cabo para poner fin a la emergencia
sanitaria vamos a analizar cuáles son
esos tres escenarios y cómo podemos
afrontarlos y también hablaremos del
aumento considerable en el número de
ciudadanos hondureños en estado de
inseguridad alimentaria el incremento se
debe a las consecuencias que dejan dos
años de lucha contra la pandemia kobe 19
y se suman a la devastación provocada
por la temporada de huracanes del 2019
veremos cuál es la situación en ese país
centroamericano
comenzamos y lo hacemos entonces con
cifras actualizando cómo ha avanzado la
pandemia de kobe 19 en cuanto al número
de contagios y fallecidos en la región
del caribe vamos a comenzar en república
dominicana que acumula ya un total de
más de 578 mil casos de kobe 19 los
fallecidos superan los cuatro mil
trescientos no muy lejos de allí la isla
de cuba contabiliza más de un millón de
casos y los fallecidos
superan los 8500 un poco más al oeste
las islas cayman suman más de 20.000 de
casos y solamente han fallecido 25
personas mientras que en jamaica allí el
total de casos es superior a los 128 mil
y los fallecidos superan los
vamos a profundizar en varios temas que
tenemos en la agenda para la consulta
con el doctor carlos eduardo pérez él es
médico infectólogo ustedes ya lo conocen
asesor científico de france24 doctor
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa quiero comenzar preguntándole
por los recientes hallazgos también los
avances que hay en cuanto a las
investigaciones que están para
determinar nuevos aspectos de la sub
variante de punto 2 que es una variante
de la variante omicron
y recordemos que las varillas peso sus
variadas son esas modificaciones que le
permiten alguna presión especial al
virus en este caso la pea dos tienen
mayor poder de transmisibilidad pero no
se ha demostrado que tengan mayor
severidad y otra cosa importante es que
las personas que están vacunadas con
refuerzo la inmunidad es efectiva es
decir que si tenemos vacunas con
refuerzo también las vamos a proteger de
esta sub variante
doctor pérez la fed autorizó en eeuu la
segunda dosis de refuerzo para personas
mayores de 50 años porque existe la
necesidad de una segunda dosis de
refuerzo ya muchas personas se sienten
incómodas porque tienen que ir a
vacunarse otra vez y porque los
refuerzos no tienen un tiempo más
prolongado de acción dentro del
organismo
realmente estas vacunas son nuevas y
después vacunas estamos aprendiendo cómo
se comporta de inmunidad y de todas
formas lo que sí se sabe es que la
inmunidad es
finita es decir no es prolongada en el
tiempo
probablemente después de seis meses se
pierden los anticuerpos en las personas
más susceptibles recordemos que son las
personas que tienen más edad y por eso
la necesidad de dosis adicionales es
probable que en un tiempo tengamos mejor
establecido que personas requieren un
refuerzo que personas no lo requieren
por ahora la recomendación a personas
que hayan durado más de seis meses sin
vacuna porque están perdiendo el
refuerzo y sobre todo personas con
comorbilidades o que sean mayores de
edad mayores de 50 o 60 años porque van
a perder de moldear y por eso se
necesitan dosis adicionales de la vacuna
doctor pérez punto importante para
consultarles lo mencionaba en el sumario
del programa ese anuncio de la o ms de
tres posibles escenarios sobre el futuro
de la pandemia de kobe y 19 dicen que
puede ser que el kobe 19 evolucione y
simplemente se vaya muriendo a lo largo
del tiempo debido a que avanza la
inmunización entre los habitantes del
planeta y desaparezca por completo de la
tierra otro escenario es que se vuelva
como una corona vido es mucho más
agresivo y hay un tercer caso y es que
simplemente convivamos con él y se
vuelva como una gripe estacional que
tiene picos sobre todo en los meses más
fríos
digamos que esto es lo que ha sucedido
en las pandemias anteriores digamos hace
100 años lo que se encontró es que este
virus de influenza el responsable de la
pandemia de 1918
pues fue atenuando es decir disminuyendo
su capacidad de virulencia en esa época
no en desarrollo de las vacunas y
digamos que eso hizo que se controlara
naturalmente la pandemia ese es el
escenario que nos plantea en la
organización mundial de la salud y lo
otro es que puede haber variantes que
puedan producir brotes epidémicos en
algunas regiones mientras más curva una
vez estemos pues menos probable que haya
diseminación de sus variantes pero
recordemos que definitivamente este
vídeo nos va a acompañar por lo menos
una década más y será el comportamiento
del virus que haya mutaciones lo que nos
va a determinar si son que disminuyan o
disminuyen su virulencia es decir que se
atenúe o que puedan en ocasionalmente
incrementar su virulencia muy
probablemente va a sesionar ya que
disminuye la evidencia lo más probable
que suceda en el futuro de la pandemia
pero eso tomará todavía un buen tiempo y
mientras tanto la vacunación y el
cuidado sigue siendo la mejor arma para
combatirlo doctor porque la emergencia
sanitaria todavía continúa pese a que
muchos países se están levantando las
restricciones paso ahora preguntarle
doctor también por otro anuncio de la ms
que presentó esta semana y fue muy
destacado a lo largo y ancho del planeta
la nueva estrategia de vigilancia
genómica para los próximos 10 años esto
que significa que van a determinar
estrategias de cara a poder investigar y
a ver cómo pueden implementar lo
enseñado lo aprendido a lo largo de esta
pandemia de kobe 19 para enfrentar
futuras pandemias o futuras epidemias
digamos que nosotros estamos
concentrados en algunos vídeos
respiratorios como los vídeos de
influenza por ejemplo y lo que está
planteando al lado de ms es ampliar esa
estrategia de tamizaje y no solamente
involucrar en estos problema virus o
virus respiratorios sino en otros virus
que pueden tener el potencial de
infectar a los humanos es muy importante
que haya una vigilancia genómica esa
vigilancia
genómica se hace en una base de datos y
cualquier hallazgo que se haga en
cualquier parte del mundo se puede
consultar a esta a esta biblioteca de
datos y se puede inferir si hay un
comportamiento agresivo o tiene
potencial pandémico o hay mutaciones que
pudieran hacerlo creo que del final de
la pandemia podemos recuperar esa
sensatez hacia que tenemos que ser
solidarios en el conocimiento y
compartirlo
para que podamos estar mejor preparados
aunque nunca nadie se prepara por una
pandemia tenemos que tener mejores
herramientas para poder enfrentar el
tamizaje nómico es necesario y en los
países de vida en desarrollo tienen que
implementarse también
doctor pérez muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros en el programa el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez desde la
ciudad de bogotá dándonos aquí algunas
aclaraciones y análisis de los temas que
le estábamos preguntando en nuestra
habitual consulta con el doctor pérez ya
que estamos hablando de dosis de
refuerzo pues miren el dato que les va a
presentar a continuación es el número de
dosis de refuerzo suministradas por cada
100 habitantes en diferentes países del
continente americano como se obtiene
este valor se toma el total de las dosis
que han sido suministradas en cada uno
de los países hasta el momento y se
divide por el total de los habitantes
del país entonces comienzo dándoles el
dato de eeuu allí han inoculado
29,42 dosis por cada 100 habitantes
seguimos en norteamérica canadá allí el
48 08 el número de dosis que han sido
inoculadas por cada 100 habitantes un
poco más al sur
de panamá allí han inoculado 33 16 dosis
de refuerzo por cada 100 habitantes la
vecina colombia pero ya en américa del
sur
2014 mientras que chile ha inoculado 83
27 dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes chile también liderando en
este índice chile ha sido uno de los
países líderes no solamente en la región
de américa latina sino también en el
mundo en cuanto a la vacunación y en el
número de dosis inoculadas en sus
habitantes
y también fue destacado esta semana en
eeuu el anuncio hecho por el centro de
control de prevención de enfermedades y
la fed que es la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos que avalaron el
uso de una cuarta dosis de vacunación
que vendría a ser una segunda dosis de
refuerzo para las personas mayores de 50
años la medida provocó diferentes
reacciones entre los ciudadanos
estadounidenses veamos luz verde para
una cuarta dosis de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 así lo anunciaron los
reguladores de salud estadounidenses
para personas mayores de 50 años hoy la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de los estados unidos
autorizó una segunda dosis de refuerzo
de las vacunas contra el cob y 19 de
fisher y bryant eco moderna para
personas mayores y ciertas personas
inmunodeprimidas
la agencia había aprobado la aplicación
de un segundo refuerzo sólo para
personas mayores de 12 años con la dosis
de facer y mayores de 18 con modernas
que tuvieran el sistema inmunitario
debilitado quienes ahora incluso podrán
acceder a una quinta dosis desde la casa
blanca aplaudieron el anuncio de
werthein
es algo bueno que los y la f ahora lo
permitan vamos a poner a disposición
para las personas mayores de 50 años y
para los inmunodeprimidos una cuarta
dosis tenemos suficientes vacunas para
que la población de esa edad pueda
vacunarse mensual
es una noticia que ha generado opiniones
divididas entre los estadounidenses
cuando sacaran una vacuna de verdad una
en la que te coloquen una o dos dosis y
ya en nuestros continuos refuerzos creo
que hay algo aquí que no está bien
que sí creo que es bueno prefiero estar
protegida lo más que pueda tuve kobe y
fue terrible y entonces no quiero
tenerlo nuevamente
el anuncio se da en medio de una
temporada donde los casos por kobe 19
han disminuido y luego de que el país
enfrentar una ola de positivos por la
variante omicron al momento el país
registra más de 80 millones de contagios
y más de 970 mil muertes
vamos a seguir profundizando en la
actualidad de eeuu vamos entonces a la
ciudad de miami a ya se encuentra antoni
welsch y para conocer más detalles hola
anthony gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa y quiero que comencemos
actualizando la situación del país en
este momento en cuanto al número de
casos el avance de la pandemia en sí y
el avance de la vacunación
hola santiago pues aquí en eeuu a pesar
de que las medidas de protección contra
el coronavirus son mínimas los expertos
sanitarios alertan de que la próxima ola
de cop 19 podría estar muy cerca
básicamente porque ya se ha confirmado
la aparición del ave a 2 una sub
variante de omicron que es muy
infecciosa y que representa el 55 por
ciento de los positivos sin embargo los
médicos dicen que aún es muy temprano
para saber realmente el impacto que
puede tener aunque por el momento sí que
ha habido un aumento de casos y se ha
convertido ya en la versión dominante
tanto en eeuu como en el resto del mundo
a pesar de este escenario preocupante
según dicen los científicos lo cierto es
que se descarta que puedan haber nuevos
confinamientos o mayores restricciones
de las que ya hay de hecho el uso de
mascarillas no es obligatorio en ningún
estado del país aunque en algunos
lugares sigue vigente la norma de
vacunación obligatoria para entrar a
ciertos lugares como teatros salas de
cine o restaurantes el problema sigue
siendo la baja tasa de vacunación que
hay en el país y que realmente está
estancada sólo el 66 por ciento de la
población tiene la pauta completa en
eeuu un porcentaje prácticamente no se
ha movido desde noviembre del año pasado
antonio y quiero preguntarle por las
reacciones y también por las impresiones
que dejan entre los estadounidenses el
anuncio de la fed a lo largo de esta
semana en cuanto a la necesidad de ser
inoculada una cuarta dosis o segunda
dosis de refuerzo dependiendo de cómo se
le quiera llamar que dicen allí
pues sí a pesar de que poco más de la
mitad de la población se ha vacunado la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu la fd ha autorizado
ya la cuarta dosis de las vacunas de
facer biotech y la de moderna eso sí
sólo para las personas mayores de 50
años y en caso de inmunodeprimidos está
cuarta dosis que supondría la segunda
vacuna de refuerzos podrían inyectarse
siempre y cuando hayan pasado cuatro
meses de la última pero de momento aún
falta la última palabra del comité de
expertos de los centros para el control
y prevención de enfermedades que son los
que tienen que acabar duluth de dar luz
verde o no a la recomendación del ente
regulador de los medicamentos en el país
en norteamericano el presidente de joe
biden en un intento de dar ejemplo y
animar a la población a vacunarse
recibió esta semana la cuarta dosis y
aseguró que el coronavirus ya no
controla la vida de los estadounidenses
pero recordó que la pandemia aún sigue
activa por eso insistía en la necesidad
de vacunarse especialmente porque eeuu
es el país más golpeado por la pandemia
más de 80 millones de contagios y 944
mil muertes a causa del virus
y también desde la casa blanca hicieron
un anuncio que existe la posibilidad de
poner fin a las restricciones en la
frontera para aceptar migrantes esto sin
duda alguna es una noticia importante
para muchos latinoamericanos que están
allí que se sabe al respecto
si la casa blanca ha confirmado esta
misma mañana que va a rescindir el
título 42 una norma sanitaria muy
polémica por la cual se podían hacer
deportaciones expresas los que buscaban
refugio en el país se calcula que más de
un millón y medio de inmigrantes han
sido expulsados a través de esta medida
una ley que fue promulgada al inicio de
la pandemia por el entonces presidente
de donald trump y que la ha continuado
el presidente joe biden hasta ahora
muchos grupos proinmigrantes la han
criticado porque consideran que esta ley
viola los derechos de los refugiados
socava la salud pública y alienta el
racismo en el país finalmente los cdc
habían dado luz verde a esta medida
porque consideraban que la entrada de
inmigrantes con kobe 19 en los centros
de detención no suponía un gran problema
para la salud pública con la derogación
de esta medida a eeuu se prepara para
recibir a más migrantes por la frontera
y la casa blanca y el gobierno también
se prepara para arrestar hasta 18 mil
indocumentados por la frontera
diariamente
antonio muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de miami en el sur del
estado de la florida seguimos haciendo
y foco en lo que sucede en eeuu porque
el presidente de eeuu joe biden aseguró
que el país está en un nuevo momento de
la pandemia pero eso sí hizo un llamado
al congreso en la ciudad de washington
para que suministre más fondos para
seguir combatiendo el kobe 19 de no
recibir estos fondos el presidente dijo
que el país podría quedarse en el mes de
mayo sin herramientas para seguir
combatiendo la pandemia de kobe 19 el
informe de nuestro compañero juan pabló
lucumí
la casa blanca pide mayor financiación
para combatir el cob y 19 en una
petición pública y directa hacia el
congreso de eeuu el presidente joe biden
sin mencionar una cifra específica le
pidió a los legisladores fondos
adicionales para suministrar las
herramientas que han ayudado al país a
hacerle frente a la pandemia un llamado
que hizo recordando que la lucha contra
el virus no es una cuestión de partidos
políticos en un congreso que en los
últimos meses ha complicado sus planes
presupuestos y propuestas de proyectos
de ley la morfina starks y más
financiación empezaremos a quedarnos sin
suministros a finales de mayo finales de
mayo congreso por favor actúen deben
actuar inmediatamente las consecuencias
de la inacción son graves sólo crecerán
con el tiempo pero no tiene que ser así
el tránsito de hour
mientras llegan los suministros del
congreso esta semana la administración
baiden presentó el sitio web que
funcionará como único método para que
los estadounidenses puedan acceder a
pruebas vacunas tratamientos contra el
virus y actualizaciones de las tasas de
contagio de sus comunidades calvet a
cada watch games people
guarden el chico vi punto gov es un
lugar en el que pueden donde pueden
hacerse una prueba y si son positivos
pueden recibir un antiviral así que este
sitio web es parte de nuestro esfuerzo y
nuestro esfuerzo continuo para
asegurarse de que las personas tienen lo
que necesitan para hacer frente al kobe
19 de pib o hardware tener sitio web
cadáveres mismos esta misma semana la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos la fda autorizó la
aplicación de una cuarta dosis a modo de
refuerzo para las mayores de 50 años y
para pacientes gravemente
inmunodeprimidos otro de los muchos
esfuerzos que el gobierno de
estadounidense hace para atacar el kobe
19 en un país azotado por las
consecuencias del virus y con más de 975
mil personas fallecidas por la
enfermedad
brevemente les presento otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en nuestro
continente comenzamos en uruguay en el
sur de américa este país tuvo esta
semana su primera jornada sin fallecidos
por kobe 19 en los últimos tres meses
uruguay no vivía una jornada sin
fallecidos desde el pasado 26 de
diciembre en este mismo mes fue
decretado el inicio de la segunda ola de
contagio provocada precisamente por la
variante omicron también brevemente les
cuento que el gobierno de paraguay
extendió la medida de reducción de
impuestos a sectores y productos entre
las medidas está la reducción del iva
para los sectores gastronómico hotelero
y para los eventos con esto buscan
mantener a flote la economía paraguaya y
también descuento que el gobierno de
bolivia presentó un programa de
reconstrucción económica para mantener
los índices de crecimiento sostenidos
del 2021 tras las dificultades que
obviamente se presentaron con la
contracción económica que dejó la
pandemia de kobe 19 o por lo menos el
punto más álgido de ella algunas de las
propuestas del plan contempla la entrega
de bonos y también algunas prestaciones
a los sectores favorecidos de la
sociedad boliviana
nos vamos ahora hasta centroamérica
porque ya son 24 millones de ciudadanos
hondureños los que están en riesgo de
inseguridad alimentaria el devastador
paso de los huracanes eta y yo está en
el año 2019 y también una temporada de
sequía a estos aspectos se sumó la
llegada de la pandemia de kobe 19 que
afectó buena parte de las cosechas y el
aparato productor de ese país
centroamericano lo que ha complicado la
situación para todos así es como están
las cosas veamos
aumenta la crisis de alimentos en
honduras según el programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu la pandemia complicó
aún más la situación en 2019 menos de un
millón de personas estaban en grave
situación de inseguridad alimentaria hoy
ese número asciende a 2,4 millones de
personas y es que el panorama para el
país centroamericano se viene
complicando desde por lo menos tres años
atrás en 2019 honduras ya enfrentaba
problemas de inseguridad alimentaria
alertada por naciones unidas luego en
2020 sufrir las consecuencias de los
desastres naturales causados por los
huracanes eta ello está y mientras el
país apenas intentaba recuperarse
comenzó la pandemia que aún hoy golpea a
los ciudadanos más vulnerables del país
la inseguridad alimentaria en honduras
es una situación que priva a la
población de poder llevar alimentos
suficientes a sus mesas para desarrollar
una vida adecuada el país sufrió una
sequía muy severa en 2019 que afectó los
cultivos lo que disminuyó la
disponibilidad alimentaria situación que
además se agudizó por los huracanes yota
y la pandemia de kobe 19 según un
informe del sistema de la integración
centroamericana la pandemia afectado a
los hondureños directamente en la
disminución de la producción de cultivos
de maíz y frijol y el alza en el costo
de la canasta básica y los combustibles
el limitado acceso a insumos generales y
la constante pérdida de cosechas
honduras con cerca de 10 millones de
habitantes cuenta con más de 10 mil
muertes a causa del joven 19 y tan solo
el 53 4% de la población está vacunada
con al menos una dosis
miren ustedes lo que está sucediendo en
perú porque allí el ritmo de vacunación
está descendiendo considerablemente por
lo menos así ha sido en los últimos
meses también en este mismo país ya
detectaron varios casos del sub linaje
ba2 de la variante o micro vamos a
profundizar para conocer cómo está la
situación allí con francisco zacarías
nuestro corresponsal que está en la
ciudad de lima hola francisco gracias
por acompañarnos hoy en el programa y
por qué están descendiendo a este ritmo
el número de vacunaciones allí en perú
qué es lo que sucede
hola santiago de acuerdo a estadísticas
presentadas por la defensoría de perú la
vacunación contra el kobe 19 presenta un
descenso de las dosis aplicadas que
pasaron de 200 9.590 en enero y 203 1952
de febrero a 133 mil 351 aplicaciones
por vía en marzo lo que representa 35
por ciento menos respecto a febrero pero
otros expertos señalan que el ritmo de
inmunización habría caído en un 54% la
defensoría ha exigido al gobierno del
presidente pedro castillo que tome las
medidas necesarias para acelerar el
ciclo de vacunación la entidad también
criticó una disminución en la colocación
de la tercera dosis en los últimos tres
meses en enero tres millones 966 mil en
febrero dos millones 516 mil y en marzo
solo 1.185.000 tiempo atrás la
defensoría había recomendado a las
autoridades sanitarias cambiar la
estrategia para que la población tenga
acceso oportuno a las vacunas
francisco viendo la prensa en perú allí
los expertos se han mostrado muy
preocupados porque han reportado casos
de la sub variante ba2 de la variante
omicron y temen que esto pueda
desencadenar una nueva ola de contagio
hoy en perú que dicen las autoridades
diversos especialistas señalan que ve a
dos de omicron andar rondando perú desde
febrero las autoridades sanitarias han
detectado 24 casos en cuatro regiones de
este país existe el temor de que vea dos
genere una cuarta ola de la pandemia
algunos expertos están preocupados por
que la cobertura de vacunación con la
tercera dosis no llega al 40 por ciento
de la población advierten que de
producirse una cuarta ola este sub
linaje de omicron afectaría
agresivamente a los adultos mayores y a
las personas con más de 2 enfermedades
ante esta situación el sindicato
nacional médico del seguro social del
perú sin and shop solicita a las
autoridades del gobierno disponer la
cuarta dosis de vacunación para las
personas mayores de 60 años con
vulnerabilidad y a los profesionales de
salud para mitigar el impacto de una
cuarta ola el gremio exige optimizar la
protección del personal de salud porque
advierten que si contraen la enfermedad
podría disminuir y hasta colapsar la
oferta de servicios en los
establecimientos de salud
francisco el foco de muchos gobiernos
ahora es tratar de sacar adelante la
economía recuperarla después de estos
dos años de pandemia como se ha visto
afectada la economía de perú y que van a
hacer para recuperar la que gestione se
está haciendo el gobierno
2020 significó para ver una caída de un
11 por ciento en su producto bruto
interno como consecuencia de la pandemia
del cobre 19 y sus efectos en la
economía en 2021 debido a un efecto
rebote y un crecimiento de la inversión
privada de 37.6 por ciento esta nación
creció a un 13.3 por ciento para este
2022 los cálculos vaticinan un 3.4 por
ciento las restricciones llevaron a
cuidados intensivos a la economía y tal
como lo señalan algunos expertos hoy
perú tiene un mercado laboral menos
productivo más desigual y precario que
el que existía antes de la crisis
sanitaria la cantidad de peruanos con
empleo informal llegó a los 9,4 millones
durante 2021 mientras que la cifra de
personas con empleo formal fue de 3.7
millones por otro lado el fondo
monetario internacional afirma que las
perspectivas de la economía peruana es
muy incierta y prevalecen riesgos a la
baja los riesgos se enlazan con la
pandemia del cobe y 19 endurecimiento de
condiciones financieras
interrupciones de la cadena de
suministros a nivel global entre
francisco pues este es un mal
transversal para todos los países de
américa latina' todos están haciendo
frente a indicadores no muy positivos
como los que usted da de perú y hay
dispositivos de varios gobiernos para
poder sacar adelante las economías
muchas gracias por este reporte desde la
ciudad de lima bueno pues ya lo decíamos
si bien la pandemia continúa pues la
vacunación sigue siendo la mejor arma
para combatirla por eso entonces
actualizamos cómo están las cifras para
el cierre de esta semana nuevamente nos
enfocamos en la región del caribe y les
traigo unos territorios muy exóticos
miren ustedes vamos a comenzar en los
territorios neerlandesas aruba allí el
75 96 por ciento de la población ya está
vacunada con el esquema completo de
vacunación en la vecina isla de curazao
el porcentaje llega al 59 77 por ciento
en los territorios de bonaire san
eustaquio y la isla de saba el esquema
completo ya alcanza el 63 29 por ciento
de los habitantes vamos a dejar de lado
las antillas neerlandesas y finalizamos
en trinidad y tobago en donde la cifra
llega al 50 52 por ciento de la
población de estos territorio insulares
nos salimos del caribe nos salimos
incluso de las fronteras del territorio
americano y nos vamos hasta china
mientras el mundo entero está comenzando
a levantar algunas de las restricciones
y también regresa a una aparente
normalidad las autoridades de la ciudad
de shanghai que es la ciudad más poblada
de china dio inicio esta semana a un
confinamiento por sectores al tiempo que
también hace pruebas de pcr a su
población para reducir la curva de
contagio de kobe 19 esto hace parte
también de su política de 0,19 en todo
el territorio chino juan pabló lucumí
nos cuenta más
el peor brote del virus desde que empezó
la pandemia tras dos años de la llegada
del cob y 19 al continente asiático
hoy shanghai la ciudad más grande de
china se enfrenta a un estricto
confinamiento las autoridades han
decidido sellar la ciudad por sectores
para tener el control del contagio entre
los más de 25 millones de habitantes
la estrategia inició confinando a los
ciudadanos del oriente de la ciudad en
pudong donde se encuentra el principal
aeropuerto internacional de shanghai y
los emblemáticos rascacielos de negocios
llegó el turno para el oeste de la
ciudad
buzzi donde los ciudadanos aprovecharon
las últimas horas antes del cierre total
para disfrutar de una comida al aire
libre hacer compras e interactuar con
sus vecinos
y pensamos que todo esto había terminado
porque empezamos de nuevo me deprime un
poco y me pone de mal humor porque
muchos de nuestros planes se han
estropeado pero no podemos hacer nada
pasamos todo el tiempo posible al aire
libre con la gente con los amigos
queremos cocinar en casa e invitar a los
amigos antes del cierre pasear al perro
ir al parque disfrutar de la vida cada
minuto antes de quedar encerrados
con la política de china de cero
contagios las autoridades desplegaron la
estrategia de confinamiento sectorizada
para evitar el cierre total y no
estropear la economía nacional el cierre
dura 5 días para cada sector pero se
prolongará 10 días más para las personas
que vivan en un edificio donde se haya
detectado un caso positivo de kobe 19
los vehículos no podrán transitar por
las vías y las personas podrán salir a
comprar productos de primera necesidad
pero sólo durante un tiempo limitado en
determinados días
y estamos de regreso en el continente
americano y nos vamos puntualmente a
centroamérica costa rica eliminó la
mayoría de las restricciones que fueron
impuestas en marzo del 2020 como parte
de su estrategia para combatir el hobbit
19 solamente van a mantener la
obligatoriedad del uso de la mascarilla
también el lavado de las manos y
mantienen la vacunación como la mejor
manera para disminuir el riesgo de
contagio de kobe 19 vamos a ir hasta san
jose hasta la capital costarricense ahí
está sin de regidor que nos va a dar más
detalles de cómo está la situación allí
cindy comienza preguntándole por este
fin de semana que es fin de semana
electoral importante de decisiones van a
tomar los costarricenses van a elegir a
su nuevo presidente que tanto ha tenido
cubrimiento el tema de la pandemia
dentro de los programas de gobierno
dentro de lo que proponen los candidatos
hay prioridad de este tema
la lucha contra la pandemia no ha sido
un tema central durante la campaña de
cara a la segunda ronda en gran medida
por el descenso de casos
hospitalizaciones y muertes
específicamente el candidato josé maría
figueres de liberación nacional prevé la
instalación de una fábrica de vacunas
que garantice las dosis para esta y
otras enfermedades mientras que el
candidato rodrigo chávez de progreso
social democrático promete de manera
general mayor eficiencia y transparencia
del sistema de salud ambos candidatos
esperan enfrentar una situación
sanitaria bajo control y han coincidido
en que priorizarán la recuperación de la
economía golpeada por los cierres y
medidas tomados por el actual gobierno
sino precisamente por la economía quería
preguntarle a algún medio costarricense
titulaba costa rica con resfrío
económico precisamente como
consecuencias de lo que le deja la
pandemia de kobe 19 cómo ha afectado
entonces qué sectores ha afectado de la
economía costarricense a la pandemia y
qué están haciendo para mejorarla
y costa rica es un país que depende
altamente del turismo y se vio afectado
por la pandemia sobre todo al inicio
cuando el mundo cerró sus fronteras y se
paralizaron las actividades sociales
unos 50 mil hogares cayeron en la
pobreza que ronda el 23 por ciento el
desempleo llegó a ser del 24% hace dos
años pero poco a poco ha ido bajando
hasta llegar a 13 7% a finales de 2021
según una encuesta del instituto de
estadística y censos el 94 por ciento de
las empresas en el país tuvo
afectaciones por la comida sin embargo
la reapertura tras la última ola ha
traído optimismo y permitido un
crecimiento en las actividades
económicas cindy para el cierre de esta
conexión cómo termina esta semana costa
rica- cuanto a número de casos personas
contagiadas y personas fallecidas
actualmente los casos de kobe 19
presentan promedios diarios menores a
1000 mientras que los ingresos
hospitalarios también se han reducido
por lo que 75 de 82 cantones bajaron de
alerta naranja a amarilla en cuanto a la
vacunación el 77% de la población ya
recibió dos dosis y un 36% ya lleva tres
cuando la mayoría de restricciones se
han eliminado aunque si se mantiene el
uso de mascarilla en lugares cerrados
muchas gracias a cindy por este reporte
desde la ciudad de san josé en costa
rica y vamos a terminar nuestro programa
dando un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia kobe 19 que
han sido destacadas en redes sociales
por diferentes medios de comunicación
comenzamos con esta publicación del
diario el colombiano de la ciudad de
medellín por supuesto en colombia los
menores entre los 12 y los 17 años
recibirán dosis de refuerzo contra el
cob y 19 esta campaña comenzó a partir
del 28 de marzo y serán utilizadas dosis
del biológico facer el refuerzo debe ser
inoculado cuatro meses después de haber
sido recibido el esquema completo de
vacunación
vamos entonces a brasil la anvisa
aprueba nuevo fármaco para el
tratamiento contra el cob y 19 se trata
de la aprobación de emergencia para el
pax lobby de la farmacéutica bayer dicho
medicamento debe suministrarse oralmente
y puede combinarse con otros que ya
están en circulación en brasil como el
mir madre vid y el ritonavir
y vamos a finalizar en cuba allí primera
vacuna intranasal contra kobe 19
desarrollada en cuba pedirá en breve
autorización se trata de la vacuna
mambisa que se suma a las otras 11
vacunas que están siendo desarrolladas
en todo el mundo para administración
intranasal en el caso de más visas
recibirá una autorización para su uso de
emergencia como dosis de refuerzo
es todo en el programa de hoy aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa nosotros
nos volvemos a encontrar la próxima
semana sigan cuidándose el kobe 19 la
emergencia persiste y sigan también
viendo france24 hasta entonces